Olha, pessoal, vocês sempre me
perguntam, doutor, quais suplementos o
senhor toma? Eu já vou quebrar o
protocolo aqui. Eu vou abrir o jogo
mesmo, mostrar exatamente o que eu tomo,
porque que eu tomo e principalmente para
explicar a lógica por trás de cada
escolha. E não é receita de bolo, mas é
transparência total com vocês. E já vou
logo avisando, quero deixar isso muito
claro aqui, que isso não é uma
recomendação para vocês tomarem, por
favor. É simplesmente eu respondendo ao
seguidor que ficou curioso para saber o
meu stack. E essa steack pode variar
também de mês a mês, de ano a ano. Então
não use isso como uma referência pétria
para vocês. Eu não vou aqui incluir
vitamina D e magnésio, porque a vitamina
D eu tomo injetável a cada 90 dias e o
magnésio eu consigo tirar da
alimentação, porque eu como bastantes
vegetais ricos em magnésio. Sabe, depois
de 28 anos na medicina e vendo de perto
como algumas doenças devastam famílias
inteiras, eu decidi que não ia ficar de
braços cruzados esperando a genética
fazer o que bem entende comigo. Eu tenho
quatro parentes com Alzheimer, quatro.
Então, minha abordagem integrativa não é
teoria, é necessidade mesmo. Vamos
começar pelo que eu chamo de meu
coquetel da manhã e da noite. É uma
formulação complexa que eu mando
manipular com 11 componentes
estratégicos. Tematuquinase, mecnogenol,
Lcitrolina, S7, norvalina, crataegos,
tadalafila, ácido hialurônico, própolis
verde, extrato de orégano, extrato de
alho rico em alicina. A natoquinase é
uma enzima fascinante que vem do NATO,
aquele alimento fermentado japonês. E
não é coincidência que os japoneses
tenham uma das maiores longevidades do
mundo. Estudos recentes, inclusive um de
2024 publicado em revistas
internacionais mostram que tuquinasi não
só dissolóve com agrosanguíneos, o que é
ótimo para prevenir derrames, infartos,
mas também tem uma propriedade
surpreendente. Ela consegue degradar as
placas amiloides do Alzheimer. É isso
mesmo que vocês ouviram. uma enzima que
ataca diretamente aquelas placas que
entopem o cérebro. Eu tomo 100 mg duas
vezes ao dia. Por quê? Porque minha
abordagem funcional olha para três
coisas ao mesmo tempo: a saúde arterial,
prevenção do Alzheimer e o controle da
disbiose intestinal. Esses três sistemas
estão conectados de forma incrível.
Quando suas artérias funcionam bem, o
seu cérebro recebe mais sangue, mais
oxigênio. Quando seu intestino está
saudável, a inflamação sistêmica
diminui. Então, um círculo virtuoso
junto com canadoquinase, eu coloco
piquogenol. E aqui eu vou contar uma
coisa. Existe uma diferença muito
grande, gigantesca entre piquenol
verdadeiro, os genéricos de casca de
pinheiro que são vendidos por aí.
Pnogenol genuíno vem especificamente do
pinheiro marítimo francês e já tem mais
de 39 estudos clínicos randomizados.
Isso significa pesquisa séria e não
achismo. O pique nojornal que eu uso 100
mg duas vezes ao dia melhora a função
hidrotelial, que é basicamente como suas
artérias se contraem relaxam. Um estudo
de 2024 mostrou que pacientes com doença
coronariana tiveram melhor significativa
na dilatação das artérias depois de usar
o piquinogenol, traduzindo, menos risco
de infarto, melhor circulação cerebral,
melhor ou menor estresse oxidativo.
A hicitrolina 200 mg é um precursor do
óxido nítrico que é fundamental para
manter as artérias flexíveis e a pressão
arterial sob controle. O S7 são um blend
de extratos vegetais que potencializa
ainda mais a produção do óxido nítrico.
Já avalina inibe a arginase, que é
enzima que degrada a arginina, mantendo
os níveis de óxonitro com mais tempo. O
crataegos, que é o espinheiro branco, é
um tônico cardíaco milenar que melhora a
força de contrasta no coração e a
circulação coronariana. E sim, eu incluo
a tadalafil 5 mg diário, o princípio
ativo dos ceares, mas em dose baixa para
uso cardiovascular, antes que alguém
faça alguma piada. A tada dafilha
melhora a função doutelial, não só
naquela região que todo mundo pensa, mas
no sistema cardiovascular como um todo.
Agora eu vou falar de um componente que
muita gente não espera numa fórmula
cardiovascular. Ácido hialurônico 200
mg. Você deve estar pensando, doutor,
ácido hialurônico não é só para
preenchimento facial? Gente, essa é uma
visão bem limitada. O ácido oral tem
propriedades anti-inflamatórias
sistêmicas e aí ajuda na hidratação
celular profunda. E tem mais, própolis
verde, 500 mg. O própolis verde
brasileiro é único no mundo por causa da
Bacaris dracunculifólia,
nossa planta típica. Ele tem
propriedades antimicrobianas potentes e
pasm também atua contra biofilos
bacterianos do intestino. Como eu tenho
disbiose intestinal com frequência isso
é fundamental para mim. Agora vou falar
de dois compostos que são verdadeiros
antibióticos naturais. Estrato de
orégano, extrato de alho rico em
alicina. O extrato de orégano que eu uso
200 mg é padronizado em carvacrol, que é
o precipativo.
Ele tem ação antifungica, antibactéria,
comparável a alguns medicamentos
sintéticos, mas sim os efeitos
colaterais. O extrato de alho rico em
alicina também, 200 mg, não é qualquer
alho, ele tem que ser alicina
estabilizada, porque ela é muito
instável e se degrada facilmente. A
licina verdadeira tem propriedades
cardiovasculares incríveis, reduz a
pressão arterial, melhora o perfil
lipítico e tem ação titrobótica natural.
Agora vou falar de dois compostos que
muita gente ainda não conhece, mas que
na literatura internacional eles estão
ganhando destaque para neuroproteção. O
primeiro é o mettiunínio, o azul de
metileno,
famoso azul de metileno. Calma, não é
aquele que você usa para atingir roupa
ou para aquário. É uma versão
farmacêutica purificada. Então, estudos
recentes mostram que o metiínio
interfere diretamente na agregação da
proteína natal, que é uma das vilãs do
Alzheimer. Diferente das placas
amiloides, os esmaranhados de tal estão
mais relacionados ao declín cognitivo
propriamente dito. Eu tomo 40 mg por dia
porque com quatro casos de Alzheimer na
família não posso me dar o luxo de não
fazer nada, não posso dar bobeira. O
segundo composto é analtrexona em baixa
dosagem. Gente, isso é medicina já de
ponta. Analxona em doses altas, é usada
para viciadas em drogas, mas em doses
baixíssimas. Eu tomo 4,5 mg por dia. Aí
ela vira o modulador do sistema imune.
Pesquisa de 2024 mostram que a
naturexona de baixa dosagem reduz a
neuroinflamação, que é um dos fatores
chaves tanto na Alzheimer quanto no
envelhecimento acelerado. A lógica é bem
simples. Quando você bloqueia os
receptores de opioides por algumas
horas, o corpo reage produzindo mais
endorfinas naturais. Eu tenho vários
vídeos no canal falando desse assunto da
naturexon de baixa dosagem. É como dar
um choque no sistema para ele funcionar
melhor. E as endorfinas não são só para
o bem-estar, elas têm propriedades
neuroprotetoras e antiinflamatórias
potentes. Agora eu vou falar do meu
complexo de metilação. Esse aqui para
quem tem tendência a homocitina alta,
como é o meu caso também para cada
baixo, que também no caso para quem
precisa modular hormônios. É uma
formulação complexa com nac, bet
bitatraticulina, betaína, vitaminas do
complexo B na forma ventilada, SAM,
exicinadinosital,
Deia, cobre queelado e clobifeno. Mas o
cobre é uma adição recente porque eu
tive um exame recente que mostrou que
ele tava baixo, mas não quer dizer que
eu tomo sempre o cobre. Então, homoistem
na alta é um marcador silencioso de
risco cardiovascular e cognitivo. Quando
ela está elevada, significa que seus
ciclos de metilação, que são aqueles
processos bioquímicos muito importantes,
não estão funcionando direito. Então,
na, que eu uso 500 mg duas vezes ao dia,
não é só para mentilação, como também um
precursor da gluta que é o nosso
antioxidante interno mais poderoso. O
bitartaraticcolina
é um precursor da citcina, é um
neurotransmissor crucial para memória e
cognição. Já betaína é um doador de
grupos metil fundamental pros ciclos de
metilação funcionário direito. As
vitaminas do complexo B que eu coloco
são todas de forma metilada,
seja B1, B2, B3, B5, peridoxal,
metilfolato, metioobalamina. Por quê?
Porque uma parte significativa da
população tem polimorfismos genéticos e
dificultam a conversão das formas
sintéticas. É como ter uma chave que não
encaixa direito na fechadura. As formas
metiladas já vem prontas para usar. O
same, por exemplo, 100 mg, é
literalmente o doador universal de
grupos metil no nosso organismo.
Fundamental para neurotransmissores,
detoxificação e reparação celular. Agora
vem uma substância que eu considero
fundamental, exanicotinatousol,
1 g por dia. Gente, isso aqui é neacina
de liberação controlada, vitamina B3 na
forma que não dá aquele flush vermelhão
no rosto incômodo. O exercantinato de
dinositol melhora dramaticamente o
perfil lipítico, especialmente HDL, que
é a minha dificuldade genética. Eu tenho
baixo, mas a mágica não para por aí. Ele
melhora a sensibilidade insulina,
otimiza o metabolismo, a glicosea, tem
propriedades neuroprotetores. O Deia, 10
mg é o precursor de vários hormônios.
Com a idade a produção vai caindo
drasticamente.
O cobre aquielado, 1 mg pode parecer
pouco, mas é estratégico. Com toda a
suplementação, especialmente o zinco,
que vem diretamente em outras fórmulas,
eu posso criar um desequilíbrio cobre
zinco. E sim, eu incluo o clomifeno na
formulação, 5 mg por dia. O clomifeno
não é só para mulheres com problemas de
fetilidade e homens, ele estimula a
produção natural de testosterona ao
enganar o hipotálamo. é uma abordagem
muito mais fisiológica do que aplicar
testosterona diretamente para quem ainda
tem capacidade de produção testicular.
Por último, o ômega-3 que vai uma dica
de ouro, não é qualquer ômega-3, eu uso
especificamente ômega-3 rico em DHA, 1 g
duas vezes ao dia. O DHA é fundamental
para função cerebral e também ajuda a
elevar o HDL, que é minha maior
dificuldade genética. Eu tenho tendência
HDL baixo e o DHA de boa qualidade
consegue melhorar isso de forma
consistente. E vocês podem estar
pensando: "Nossa, doutora, é muito
suplemento e tem razão, mas olhem por
esse ângulo. Cada composto que eu
escolhi tem múltiplas funções. A
natoquinase protege o coração e o
cérebro. O pqunoginal melhora a
circulação e combate o estresse
oxidativo. E o mettionínio, a natural
especificamente os mecanismos do
Alzheimer. É uma estratégia integrada,
não multipílula aleatória. Tem mais uma
coisa importante. Eu monitoro tudo
sempre com exames regulares. Steína,
lipidongrama completo, marcadoras
inflamatórias, perfil hormonal. Não
adianta tomar suplemento, como diz, né,
no escuro. Tem que saber se está
funcionando, ajustar doses, personalizar
a abordagem. O legal é que cada vez mais
a ciência está confirmando que a
prevenção ativa não só evitar o que faz
mal, mas dar ativamente o que faz bem e
o futuro da medicina. E quando vocês têm
predisposição genética para alguma
doença, como eu tenho paraer, essa
abordagem integrativa deixa de ser
opcional e ver a questão de
sobrevivência mesmo. Obviamente o que
funciona para mim não vai funcionar
igualmente para vocês. Vai depender de
uma série de fatores, genética, estilo
de vida, medicamentos, tudo isso
influencia. Mas a lógica por trás das
escolhas, combater inflamação, otimizar
a metilação, proteger o sistema
cardiovascular e o cérebro. Essa lógica
vale para todo mundo. Lembrando que ao
longo do vídeo eu falei de DHA e DHEA,
né? DHA é um tipo de ômega-3 e o dhea é
um precursor hormonal, tá? Então, se
você não entendeu, volta o vídeo e revê
o que eu acabei de falar.
Agora saia do vídeo se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade conveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens e
omitir protocolos controversos. E na
comunidade fechada de membros aqui do
YouTube não existe filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica. Casos de reversão
que parecem possíveis, combinações of
label que funcionam, fornecedores
confiáveis, interpretação avançada de
exames. E é basicamente ter acesso ao
meu cérebro médico sem intermediário.
Então temos lives semanais respondendo
perguntas, PDF com mais de 47 protocolos
exclusivos, grupo no WhatsApp. Se você
quer a medicina funcional real, clique
em seja membro. Não é para curiosos, é
para quem quer resultados.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem.
A vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do Doutor Além do Trenova.